(upbeat music)
- Welcome to another
episode of The Addy Hour,
our 20th episode, which
I'm very grateful about.
We've been doing this since
about February of this year.
So it's really been nice to
see this come to fruition
in a lot of ways.
Today, I'm honored to be able
to host another conversation
on a really important topic.
We're gonna be talking
about depression, ketamine,
and just important
considerations about navigating
the mental health care system.
So as usual on this podcast,
some really important, some heavy topics,
but it's also gonna be
encouraging, I think as well,
just as we talk through
some of these experiences
from our two guests,
both from a provider
standpoint and from someone
who's walked through the system
and they're actually working
together as colleagues
in this moment as well.
So I'll let them elaborate
on that as we go through.
But I'm honored to be
able to welcome two guests
to the podcast today.
The first of which is Dr. Gerry Sanacora.
Dr. Sanacora is the Gross
Professor of Psychiatry
at the Yale School of Medicine.
He's also the director
of the Yale Depression
and Research program
and the co-director
of the Interventional Psychiatry Program
at Yale New Haven Hospital.
He's someone who's been
engaged in research
for over 25 years using both
pre-clinical rodent models
and also human clinical studies
to really understand the biology
of neuropsychiatric illnesses.
And also to really think about
and develop new approaches
for treating and
preventing those illnesses
in the first place.
He's someone who's led a
lot of different projects,
projects within the National
Institutes of Health,
projects have been
sponsored by foundations,
projects that have been
sponsored within the industry.
So it has a lot of experiences
in different realms.
And what is really impressive
is that he's also worked
on creating and disseminating
educational resources
and also providing leadership
to both national and
international consensus
on international consensus statements.
He's won numerous awards for his work.
He's a fellow
of the American college of
Neuropsychopharmacology.
He also received
the Anna-Monika Stiftung
International Award
and received a Joel Elkes Research Award.
So I'm grateful for the work
that he does in this space
and honored to welcome Dr. Gerry Sanacora
to The Addy Hour podcast.
- Thank you, Nii.
It's really a pleasure to be here.
- Thanks so much for being here.
My second guest is Ashley Clayton.
And Ashley is someone
who describes herself
as a person who loves stories,
as an avid reader of poetry,
memoirs and nonfiction.
She also finds joy and comfort
in music and impressively,
during the pandemic, has picked up
and has been teaching herself the banjo.
Ashley is someone who grew up
in the Rolling Hills of Kentucky,
moved to Connecticut for grad
school and has been living
in Connecticut for the past 12 years.
She has a master's degree
in community psychology
and is also a research associate
in the Department of Psychiatry
at the Yale School of Medicine.
She initially ventured into
the community psychology space
through a determination to
use her firsthand experience
with mental illness for the greater good.
And she's also very
dedicated to social justice.
So she's a mental health
advocate, or activist rather.
She's also published
numerous research papers
on social inclusion of individuals
living with severe mental illness,
on maternal mental health,
on recovery-oriented and
person-centered care,
and has also written healthcare
narratives and essays.
She's on the advisory board
of different organizations.
Also owns a consulting business
where she provides consultation
in program evaluation
and patient engagement.
So I'm deeply grateful
for all the important work that she does.
And also thankful that she's
taken time to join us here
on The Addy Hour podcast.
- Yeah, thank you so much for having me.
I'm looking forward to our conversation.
- Definitely.
Definitely looking forward to it
and grateful to both of you.
This, in some sense, is
an in-house conversation
since we're all at Yale,
but also we wanna make sure as
we always do on this podcast,
that we're just communicating
to the general public as well.
And so I'm grateful for the ways
you all have done that already.
And I know that this conversation
is gonna continue to do that as well.
But as I always do on the podcast,
I always like to check in
and see how people are doing overall.
Especially as we wrap up 2020,
as we look forward to 2021.
And Ashley, why don't we
go ahead and start with you
and just see how you're
doing in this moment?
- Yeah.
I think the most honest answer
to that is I am both okay
and very much not okay.
So I think, the last, we're coming
into this two years of a pandemic.
And I think we're all sharing that stress.
There's a low level or
sometimes a high level
of just general
overwhelmed stress fatigue.
So definitely, feeling that.
I think my life during
the pandemic personally
has been challenging aside from everything
we're all experiencing together.
The day that Connecticut shut down.
My brother, they found the second tumor.
He had a glioblastoma.
So at the exact moment
that everything happened,
our world, my family
life got pretty chaotic.
And so he died earlier this year
and that's been very painful and sad.
So I've been in also a process
of mourning and grieving,
but also being away from my family,
not being there as much as I wanna be.
So, and in 2020 I had
three job transitions,
which is stressful.
I've had some pretty
strange health issues,
physical health issues.
So dealing with those.
But I also feel okay in some weird ways.
So I think the most honest answer
is really I'm okay and not okay.
And I think a lot of
people can relate to that.
- Yeah.
And I think that's such an important piece
to just get across.
I mean, just the level of candor
that you just shared
as well with everything
that you've gone through
in the last two years.
And the fact that you can have
both of those simultaneously,
being okay and not okay,
I think a lot of ways,
and people have heard this
on this program before,
but that's validating, I think
for a lot of people to hear.
'Cause sometimes, I think people feel
stuck in one or the other.
Like either I have to not be doing well.
People always have room to have both
and I think that's really
important knowledge
that you're sharing that.
So really appreciate that.
Gerry, what about you?
How are you doing in this moment as well?
- Ashley captured it extremely concisely
very well in many ways.
And it's been a difficult,
Professionally, it's been a
hard year, as you can imagine.
It's been extremely busy and
trying to adapt to working
in environments that
we're not prepared to work
and doing so much.
By telemedicine and a lot
of the treatments we give
are actually hands-on
and trying to figure out
how to do that.
When the volumes are so high,
but yet all the procedures
that we need to ensure safety
become so much more time-consuming.
It's been a struggle, but overall,
I have to consider myself
one of the real lucky people
that has not been directly
personally affected
by this pandemic.
And that has been extremely fortunate.
The burden has not been shared evenly
from everybody that see.
- Yeah, that's very true as well.
And again, so much, Ashley,
I just appreciate the way
you shared that, honestly,
'cause I think sometimes as well,
and that's also come up that people
who haven't been directly affected
sometimes lessen the challenges
they have also faced.
So, I mean, for you as a provider,
obviously, that's also very challenging.
But at the same time, as you mentioned,
you do have a place of
thankfulness being blessed
and privileged to not have
been directly affected.
So I appreciate you putting
that in context as well.
And again, even as we're starting,
that's one of the reasons
why I was so I'm grateful
that both of you have joined.
Just a level of candor
with which you both speak
and the honesty and the realness,
I think goes a very, very long way.
Another question that I wanted to ask,
I may allude to this in the introduction,
but you all have had a
shift in your relationship
over the years,
but I also just want to start
and ask how the two of you met.
In what context and how that
relationship has changed
and developed over the years.
So whoever wants, I know best person
to ask to introduce that,
but I'll let you all decide, I suppose.
- Sure.
Is it okay if I go?
Oh yeah, definitely.
- Please do.
- So I met Gerry in early part of 2016.
So I was hanging out with a
colleague, our mutual colleague,
but we're all colleagues so, of ours.
And I had really, at this point,
been struggling really
severely with depression
for the last few years,
but was the first time,
I was actually having
what we call functional impairments.
I was having some cognitive
deficits struggling at work
just look at my spreadsheet and be like,
I don't know what to do.
And so actually was on a
partial medical leave from work,
which was the first time
I ever needed to do that.
And so I had reached out to a colleague
who does some research with ketamine
in a different area than depression,
and just said, hey,
I remember you saying something
about ketamine and depression,
could you meet and talk?
And so he actually referred
me to Gerry who at the time
was running a phase two clinical trial.
And so, he made a call on
my behalf later that week.
I met with Gerry to really talk
about his research projects and to see,
am I a good candidate
for any of the studies he has going on?
And is it something that if I am,
I would wanna move forward with?
And so that's really how we met first
and kind of a principal
investigator, physician,
patient research, research
participant relationship.
And I did end up participating
in some clinical trials
throughout that year.
And he was involved
after the study is ended
and the transition of my care
over to a team I have now.
But in the last few years,
we've really established our
relationship as colleagues,
as people who really wanna talk publicly
and have to have good conversations
about what is it like to
live with severe depression,
what treatments are available,
all of these different things together.
That's a path I think
we really wanted to do.
So we've separated our
doctor-patient relationship really,
and have established a firm
relationship as colleagues
here in the university, so.
- I look at it from the perspective,
there are many good doctors
that could do what I was doing
to help Ashley, but there are
very few people like Ashley
that could really help
us understand better
how to provide the best
care we can to patients.
And I think our collaboration
through this sentence
is real important.
And I know you do have
good care elsewhere.
There are more good doctors
than there are people like you.
- Thank you.
- Wow, wow.
Yeah, that's really powerful
I think in a lot of ways.
And just to be able to have,
I mean, I'm speculating here,
but I would say that kind
of relationship is rare.
To have that collegial relationship
and then people who are mutually invested
and willing to learn from
each perspective as well.
And I think that goes,
we'll get into this as well,
but that probably goes a long
way into helping both sides
see blind spots that we might
not have seen otherwise,
I think is really important.
I did wanna pick up Ashley on one aspect
that you mentioned too,
in terms of walking
through severe depression.
Because I think that's a conversation
that's really important.
That has talked about
in society has come up
in this podcast as well.
But I think sometimes from
a general perspectives,
the lack of clarity on what
people mean when they say, okay,
I'm feeling depressed
versus clinical depression
versus severe depression.
And so how, as you both
have talked about this
in public sense, how do you
usually help people understand
what those phrases mean and
what the distinctions are?
Actually, I guess we can start with you
and then maybe go to Gerry from there.
- Sure, yeah.
So I think there is a completion
of depression and sadness.
That they are one in the same.
That when I'm feeling sad or down
about something that I'm
depressed, we use that term
very flippantly and often,
And that is not true.
I also think clinical depression
can look really different
for different people because you can have
what I like to call like a
constellation of symptoms.
And so someone's clinical depression,
even if we're categorizing
as clinical depression
can look really different
than someone else's.
So I think it's important to talk about,
and I'll just speak
mostly to my experience.
And I'll let Gerry
do all of, from a clinical perspective,
these are kind of the lines
that we draw or what we mean
or what is meaningful.
But I often refer to what I'm living with
is severe depression
or really difficult to treat depression.
And I think for me,
if you think about
depression as a spectrum
and you have this, oh,
things aren't feeling, right,
I'm feeling down, I'm feeling fatigued.
Maybe I'm not sleeping,
I'm feeling restless.
And there's a whole
spectrum of where that goes
to where I feel like my
depression when it's not treated
or well-managed goes real fast.
Which is this overwhelming fatigue
that my bones feel like they
are hollow but need of iron.
Like there's nothing in them.
It's an empty feeling,
but it's a heavy feeling.
I often feel like there's just like
someone's sitting on my chest
and I have to work to breathe.
Not in the same way like I'm panicked
and I'm struggling to breathe,
but it just like, it feels laborsome.
There's also, I tend to
have like a loss of affect.
Of like, I'm a person, I
feel things really deeply.
I'm a deep thinker in introspective.
And I will know all these
things intellectually,
but I will look at my
husband and I might not have
any feelings toward him.
That's really painful to experience.
And I think for me in particular,
and one thing I probably
don't do a good enough job of,
saying because to me,
they go together so well,
but it's not true is my
depression is often accompanied
by pretty intense suicidal ideation.
And that's not true for everyone.
Even people who have severe depression
might not have suicidal ideation.
But mine tend to be pretty
close one in the same.
And so, before I met Gerry
and before I was in the studies
and I was walking around
for four years and every single day,
and it just got progressively worse.
And by the time I met
Gerry, every single minute,
all this I was thinking about
is like how much I wanted to die.
And like what a burden that is to carry
and just how paralyzing that can be.
And I think depending on the
constellation of symptoms
I have as an adult, I
didn't when I was younger,
have what I refer to as
these functional impairments.
But I have trouble seeing
the future thinking past.
Sometimes I can't even think past a day.
Sometimes I can't even think past an hour.
Which makes it really
hard to problem solve
and tolerate and do anything.
So I think there's a range there,
but for me personally, my
experience, that's what I mean.
- Yeah, I think that's
really helpful just the way
that you've painted that picture
and even the bravery
in sharing that as well
because I'm imagining people
who've walked through that themselves,
hearing someone else talk about it,
how helpful and validating that could be.
And for those who have
friends and loved ones
who don't always know how to
respond or how to react to it,
just hearing that personal perspective,
I think is so helpful in terms of context.
Really appreciate the way
that you've painted that.
And also just clarified some
of the distinctions as well.
'Cause you're right, we do
use it, not intentionally,
but it really is important
to have that distinction
so people can really understand
the differences as well.
Gerry, anything you want--
- I think--
- Oh, go ahead, Ashley.
- I was just gonna say the one thing
that I also think about is we
also didn't think of happiness
as the opposite of depression.
And happiness might, I'm not convinced,
but might be the opposite
sadness, which is not depression.
Andrew Solomon said it.
And he was like,
"The opposite of
depression isn't happiness.
The opposite of depression is vitality."
I feel like that, like
yes, those things feel.
- Yeah, that's really good.
That reminds me of what
you said the onset too,
just that you can be okay and
now okay at the same time.
And that that can be a good place to be.
It can also be a challenging place to be.
And there's not one
static response to that,
but even that in itself doesn't convey
a sense of happiness all the time.
Which I think sometimes like you said,
people are looking for,
but that's just not the reality
of successfully navigating
mental health in general.
So really appreciate that as well.
Gerry, anything that you wanna add there,
even in terms of a big picture,
painting that picture for us?
- Yeah, actually, I
pick up on a few things
that Ashley said, but I
think psychiatry in general
is really plagued by having a lexicon
that overlaps so much with lay language.
And these words like
feeling depressed and said
are get used interchangeably
where they really aren't.
Sadness is a symptom of depression.
And we use a lot of words in psychiatry,
in our common conversations
that we have a different clinical meaning
when we're really being specific about it.
But I think the other issue
that Ashley touched upon,
which is so critical
is depression is truly,
it's what we call a
wastepaper basket diagnosis.
Meaning it's a diagnosis of exclusion.
So you have these set
of symptoms and signs
and we can't find a reason for them.
If we find a reason for them,
you don't have depression.
If you have hypothyroidism,
you have hypothyroidism.
If you're early stage
Parkinson's, you have Parkinson's.
So depression by definition is something
that we can't really identify.
We don't have a positive
test for depression.
We have symptoms and we rule
out all the other alternatives.
And if you can't find anything,
we're left with the
diagnosis of depression.
And that alone, as you could imagine,
makes it a very heterogeneous disorder.
I mean, there are probably
many different ways
you can get to that end point
of having those signs and symptoms.
So it makes it very difficult then.
And again, following with
what Ashley was saying,
it isn't a sort of dichotomous thing
where you're depressed or not depressed.
In fact, most people don't fit that thing.
It's on a continuum of how far.
And not only just on a continuum,
it's probably not a single axis.
So it probably is not happy to sad.
In fact, neurobiologically,
it's not same brain regions
that control things like reward
and control things like anxiety.
There's actually different
brain regions that are involved.
And there's no reason to think
that this is on a slide
rule that you just go
from one to the other,
there's probably multiple
different axes involved
in the way you're feeling.
So very long winded way of saying
it's complicated and complex.
I really, for me, it boils down
to the functional impact
on somebody's life
and the quality of life and
those two big issues determining
whether it needs to be treated.
How it needs to be treated,
it is a very individualistic
type model to approach.
- Yeah, but I definitely
appreciate that context as well.
And especially functionality is I think,
for many of us who are
mental health advocates,
that's something we often talk about.
Whether people notice a significant change
that's impairing day to day functioning.
Our day-to-day activities,
there's a big shift from
people's normal interactions
in the world.
But then I was also
curious what you mentioned
about the exclusion piece
and for either of you, I'm curious.
Does that ever become a point
of frustration for patients?
I can imagine somebody saying,
well, you're just ruling out
everything else and saying,
so it must be depression.
And that, as a patient,
I can imagine that would feel
very frustrating in itself.
Are you sure it is?
Or what's underlying, and just
kind of a feeling of unknown?
Well, it's just this, because
we can't find anything else.
How do those conversations?
- I promise you as a
clinician and as a scientist,
it's very frustrating too.
I think it's humbling.
And I approach this by saying,
I let people know that
just because we don't know
exactly what it is
doesn't mean we don't know
how to provide treatment.
We don't know how to make things better.
We can know that without knowing exactly
what's going on neurobiologically
or having the perfect diagnosis.
To take it to the extreme.
I always remind people that Newton
isn't completely right
in classical physics,
but it's still enough way can build
the Empire State Building
and have it standing
for hundreds of years.
So we can have enough of an understanding
to understand how to treat these,
but we really don't know
the underlying neurobiology
for depression.
It's something I know
you're working hard at,
our lab is working hard at.
I think we're getting closer year by year,
but we're not there yet.
- Ashley, anything that you
wanted to add on that point?
Both either as an activist
or as someone walking through
and navigating mental
illness over the years.
- Yeah, yeah.
So, I would say sounds terrible,
but you're lucky if you find
a doctor who's also gonna look
for other things and not
assume it's depression.
Where the might be, the rule-out of,
we looked for all these other things,
but I think depending on what kind of care
you have access to,
and maybe even where
you live in the country
and maybe who that first
doctor is that you encounter.
They may or may not look for other things.
And I've struggled with
some form of mental illness
pretty much since I was in middle,
I would say at least middle
school, if not sooner.
I had a pretty traumatic
childhood and had a lot
of symptoms of PTSD
and started self-harming
when I was very young.
And so I didn't have the same,
I don't have the same intense story
as some people who might
become depressed as an adult,
or might have their first
onset or episode later.
It was pretty smack in my face.
Like something's really terribly wrong.
And so I was connected with
care at a pretty young age.
And I've been fortunate that
I've had continued access
to care that my parents
had good health insurance,
that I was able to go to good hospitals.
I was in and out of hospitals.
And had pretty good team for awhile.
And I would say, definitely
depression there,
but they're all arbitrary lines,
but it was mostly really
kind of post-traumatic stress
and in reactions to being
in some pretty not great situations.
And I've been really fortunate
that I've had a lot of therapy for that
and some time has passed where
that although, it's still
there and still comes up
and bubbles up from time to time
really isn't something
that kind of interferes
with my daily life in a way.
But what as an adult, as that subsided,
I think, there was a process
where I think depression
really set in and took over
and has been the thing that I think
has been a continuous struggle
for me for the last 10 years.
So for me, it was a little clearer.
I do also have, I have
an autoimmune disorder
and I think we have just discovered
that I have a primary immune deficiency.
And I know you had a guest
who was talking about that.
He has a much more severe case than I do.
But as a patient who fatigue,
it's something I really struggle with,
and it's a symptom of depression
and it's a symptom of
an autoimmune disorder.
And then just in the last three months,
have found out, oh, I have
these other deficiencies that,
when those are fixed, maybe
I'll have some energy.
So I also get the frustration
of my psychiatrist
being like, it's your
auto immune disorder.
And my rheumatologists being
like, it's your depression.
And we're all just, and I'm like,
I don't care but someone, please fix it.
So I appreciate that part too, so.
- And I do.
- Yeah, I do, I just wanna make sure
that that the point I made previously
and following up on what
Ashley said is clear.
I mean, I think we need to be honest
and be clear that we don't know
the real underlying neurobiology.
But that shouldn't be taken to mean
that we don't know what to do.
We have to treat and help people.
And is actually saying what we call it
is actually less important than knowing
how to have treatments that are effective.
And Ashley's right.
We're right on the cusp
of understanding the role
that neuroinflammation or
neuroinflammatory disease
could have or immune
deficiency in these disorders.
And so we don't really know the cause.
And hopefully someday, we
can say nobody has depression
because we can identify
what it is, then treat it.
But as it is, we're pretty good
about treating the general
diagnosis as it stands today.
It could be better and
we're getting better,
but as it is, we're pretty good.
- Yeah, yeah.
And that's definitely well-taken as well.
And even, not always knowing the reason,
but at least being able to move forward
in the treatment phase as well.
On that note, I also
wanna pick up on something
that Ashley mentioned as well
just in terms of having providers
who were in that mindset
and trying to make sure
that they treated the depression.
And this in a sense,
is a little bit bigger than
the depression topic itself.
And just mental health in general,
as we've also talked
about on this podcast,
just not only access to care,
but how providers react to
people from different backgrounds
and the aspects of how race
plays in, racism or zip code,
and whether that is uniformly
accessible across the board.
But even say, getting past that level
of saying that is accessible,
let's make that assumption,
even though we know that's
not true universally.
But even once that is provided, Ashley,
you've talked a lot about just
navigating the system as well
and the ups and downs that
you had in that process.
So thinking about your 2019 piece,
my struggle to access
lifesaving mental health care,
I was wondering if you could
actually just take us through,
as we move to that topic,
how you went about putting
that piece together.
What was that process like for you?
- Sure, yeah.
Of writing the article or?
- Yeah.
What motivated you to
actually put it out there?
- Yeah, sure.
I like to get people up to speed
if you haven't read the piece.
But like I said, I met Gerry.
I was in some clinical
trials 'cause unfortunately,
I was one of those people
who we didn't know really
how to treat my depression.
I had a very good doctor and
I'm what I like to consider
a very good patient.
I'm willing to try things.
And if I'm not, I'm gonna tell you
and we'll get a better plan,
but I'm willing to hang in there and see.
And so, I mean, we had been trying
for at this point, two years,
different combination of some medicines,
different classes of
medicines, all sorts of things.
I was running, I was doing yoga.
I was behaviorally doing
everything I should be doing.
I was in therapy.
I switched to another kind of therapy.
And I was getting worse.
So by the time I found Gerry,
I think everyone was just
like, I don't know what to do.
And I was lucky that I did
respond really well to ketamine.
And we can talk about that later.
Which is what I received
in the clinical trial.
But in that process of
enrolling in a clinical trial
and you get access to this care
that you can't get otherwise.
It's still being studied and ketamine
because it is FDA approved
for other reasons,
you can access it unlike
if it's experimental drug
without any kind of approval.
But then the question always
is like, what do you do after?
What do you do after the study ends?
What do you do after the protocol ends?
Protocols are different.
Sometimes, you have continued access.
Sometimes it's a one and done thing.
And so, we were in that
situation of, oh my gosh,
I found something.
I responded super well to it.
I can't get access to it otherwise.
My insurance isn't gonna pay for it.
It's very, very expensive.
There are very few
people, who at that time,
were receiving it.
Ketamine on an off label outpatient basis.
And I ended up in the
hospital for over a month
on full medical leave.
I tried electroconvulsive therapy
because that is the gold standard
and that was the best option.
We had really exhausted options.
And unfortunately, I just didn't
respond to that treatment.
And so after that process,
Gerry and some other physicians
at Yale New Haven Hospital
were able to get me into the program
to be able to receive ketamine
outside of a study setting,
really to save my life.
But it was, I mean, I'll
let Gerry speak to it too.
I mean, it was a terrible,
terrible struggle
where it was treatment
by treatment approval
by whoever the administrators are.
And love you, thank you for
doing that and saving my life.
But really, it was somewhat
out of the doctor's control
or quite out of the doctor's control.
And it was particularly frustrating
'cause I knew there was
something that worked.
It wasn't like, I didn't have any hope.
Like I knew I was like, if you
can get me this, I will live.
And I think being that
unwell and having to advocate
for treatment and it was exhausting.
The tiny resources I had left
that I could have been using
to try to replenish
some internal resources
to make the case or connect
with the right person
or I mean, I feel like I
was willing to beg to do,
I will do anything
because I'm going to die.
And it was terrifying.
And I was so lucky.
And so I think once I got
approval to receive this treatment
for free, like on that day,
look, if it hadn't happened that day,
I'd had a conversation with one
of my doctors and just said,
like, I don't think you guys
understand how unwell I am.
And it's gonna be too late.
If we don't fix this,
it's gonna be too late.
And had I walked out that
day with a different answer,
it certainly would have been too late.
I mean, that's where I was.
And I think, I quickly felt well
after about a month of treatment
which was such a blessing
from being so unwell. But
But I knew that like luck
played a huge role in that.
And that made me very, very unsettled
and scared as a person.
And I also recognized
like of this situation,
I am better situated than 99.5% of people
to have negotiated this
and gotten through it.
I mean, I'm white, I'm well educated.
I'm very well connected.
I worked in the Department of Psychiatry.
Half of my friends are
psychiatrist or psychologist.
I mean, I had been in the
system for a long time.
So I know about the healthcare system.
I research it.
I mean, I just was so
well-equipped and I almost died.
And I was like, oh, this is what happens.
This is how people fall
through the cracks.
And this is how people
die because not everyone
is as well resourced
and connected as I am.
And so that was what
motivated it part and part.
And part of it, it was selfish.
I was terrified it was gonna happen again.
And I needed to have a
better system because I knew
that I will not get lucky twice.
And I also knew, like,
I wouldn't say if I had to do
it again, I wouldn't survive.
I still kind of believe that of like,
it is remarkable that I survived
and I'm so thankful for that.
But if I had to do it again,
I'm still not sure I would.
And so I wrote this piece in
part for me to have like, yes,
to help others and build a
better system and try to think
about things differently.
But then also selfishly, I was like,
I almost died and I don't
want that to happen again.
- Yeah.
I'm grateful that you're here.
Grateful that you took
the time to write that
on so many levels.
But at the same time,
it's so sobering as well.
Just to hear how close that was,
even with all the resources
that you had access to.
And I say that not in the
sense that you had access
to everything you needed,
but comparatively,
as you mentioned, to others who not have
those same resources and even still.
- And well, resources, but
also like the best doctors.
The people who are at
the top of the field,
cutting edge, everything.
And then also who are just
like very good humans.
So it really was like the
perfect situation to be in,
except for, it was a whole hot mess
because the system is very
broken, if there is a system.
- Yeah, and Gerry, go ahead.
And I just wanna hear
your your perspective too
and your reactions in those moments.
And even as you and Ashley have continued
to talk through this--
- So there is the aspect
where things the system,
I don't even know if it's fair
to say the system is broken
and I'm not quite sure
it was ever put together
properly to be broken.
But obviously, the system
is a tremendous challenge.
And especially in getting
behavioral health care
or mental health care.
But the positive side,
actually sort of this
was seeing how people, when
you put them in a room,
including the physicians that
really worked hard for this,
but the hospital administrators,
we were very fortunate to
be at a university hospital
where hospital administrators
really worked hard
to make this happen.
But even the third-party
payers, the insurance companies.
When we got to talk to
the people from there,
there are real people behind
that want to help people.
So I think I was very
encouraged by the fact
that individuals want to
make the system better.
But the system, again,
I'm not even sure I can
say needs a major overhaul
because I'm never quite
sure it was put together,
the work made to begin with.
But clearly the mental health
system in this country,
but throughout the world is
not prepared for the need
that's placed on it right now.
It's a tremendous burden and
the cost of it is substantial.
And we have to figure out a way
of delivering all treatments
more efficiently and effectively,
or else, we just can't afford to do this.
- That's very so, so true.
And again, I mean, just the weight of it
and the impact and the sobering
nature as you both share,
but actually, especially as
you've shared your story,
and I know you shared some
suggestions in the piece as well,
but I'm curious how, I
mean, that came out in 2019.
Have these conversations moved in?
How have you all, both in
your individual spheres
and even collectively tried
to move things forward to,
I don't know the right word
if it's not fixing the system,
but to get to a place that's better.
'Cause I mean, Ashley, I agree with that.
I mean, it's a matter of life and death.
There's a lot of situations
to be completely frank.
And how do we ensure and move forward
to more likelihood of life?
- Yeah, so, I'm really thankful
for the relationship I have with Gerry
in part because I get to be
in conversations like this.
Where I get to share my story
both to help those who are suffering
feel like they're not
alone and a path forward,
but also I think to speak to
the gravity of the situation.
And I don't think we, as a
society, appreciate that.
Of how life threatening depression can be
and how immediately urgent
and emergent it can be.
And we definitely don't fund it
the way we fund other illnesses
of similar severity or threat.
It was interesting in this process in 2016
when I was on my first medical leave.
My brother was on his medical leave
after having brain surgery from,
that was, he had cancer
and we would talk about how
different our experiences were
and how both socially and who
knew that we were on leave
and who brought casseroles.
And that whole thing of just like,
it is treated very differently.
But there was a point at which
I'm not at that point anymore
and I'm not comparing depression to those,
I'm not saying what I
have is the same thing
what my brother had, you know I mean?
The trajectories are less certain,
there are all sorts of major differences.
But there was a point where like my life
was in severe jeopardy if
I didn't have treatment.
And so I think really sharing that
and getting that message out,
I think to put some urgency behind it,
of like, one, you need
access to treatment.
And two, we need access
to better treatments.
Because what about those of us
who aren't responding
to what's already there?
And I think the other thing,
I comment on quite a few
things in this article
about research and how can
we make it more beneficial
to participants who sign up.
And I have some suggestions for that.
And I know, the interventional
psychiatry services
has taken some of those suggestions.
But the funding and I think
reimbursement for care.
And like Gerry said, it's very expensive.
I mean, I still receive free care,
which, I have a lot of feelings about.
Really complicated feelings about.
But definitely gratitude for sure,
but lots of complicated feelings.
And here I am, I told you
I had some health issues
in these past few years
and one of the medications,
one of the treatments I might take
is gonna be $10,000 a month,
which is much more than
my ketamine bill is,
but my insurance is gonna pay for it
without much question of like,
once these things are proven
and we have these labs
to say this, you can get this treatment
that's very expensive and
like have access to it.
Whereas like we have, I don't
know how many years of data,
I've probably had 130
ketamine treatments and like,
we have very good data that show
that when Ashley can get this
treatment, she is pretty well.
And still can't make that case.
So I don't think that necessarily
answered the question.
I'm trying to remember what it was, but.
- That's still helpful.
I mean, that's the context for all it.
- Yeah, I think Ashley highlights
many of the biggest problems we face,
but the issue of providing affordable,
efficient and effective
behavioral health care is immense.
I mean, it's huge.
And I don't think it's possible
to target it at one spot.
It really is the whole system.
We need to be able to
have early recognition.
We need to have access to treatment.
We need to have what we
call the appropriate level
or step-based care.
'Cause as we talked about depression,
it's a very heterogeneous illness,
not only heterogeneous it's one
that the evidence is pretty clear.
If you can address it early,
you could prevent later
progression to more severe
and treatment resistant stages.
And then obviously for
the unfortunate people
that don't have early responses
that we have access to these
really cutting edge treatments.
And it's hard to do one
of those in isolation.
Really, the demand is just so much greater
than the supply of the system.
It's just impossible for every
person who needs to be seen
by a behavioral health
specialist to be seen.
There's just not enough around.
And especially for everybody to be seen
by fully trained psychiatrists
but there's appropriate levels of care
that can be initiated and
the early you can do that,
the less expensive or
less costly those are.
So it's a major overhaul of the system
that needs to be done.
I think we're getting there.
And as I said, I'm trying to infuse
a little optimism to that
I think people really care.
And I think even people think,
the insurance companies,
they're just, I can say when
I talk to the individuals
that people do care.
Just how do you make this work fiscally.
It's not an easy solution, but
it's something we need to do.
And I think now more than ever,
where we're seeing that
it's reached a crisis point
especially for psychiatric disorders,
especially for depression,
that the impact that's
having on the country,
that the burden on the country.
Both economically, but
even just personal pain
is just not tolerable.
- Yeah, definitely agree with you.
And although people may feel
like we're not giving a lot of answers.
I think part of it is
just the awareness too.
Because for those of us and
I put myself tangentially
in that category, but in the field,
conversations that we've
been having for a while,
but as much of these
conversations need to be expanded
and enlarged and in scope so
that the system can be changed,
because just in small pockets,
that's not gonna do it as
you were alluding to as well.
So I think it's brilliant.
- I mean, these are issues
that are nationwide in
terms of reimbursement
and in terms of how do you
bring these novel treatments
to actual clinical care.
Like you, I grew up, my background's
in physiology and biophysics.
I'm a pretty basic scientist at heart.
And I always had the idea
that if we understood
the basic physiology, we
could develop good treatments.
The rest is easy.
Now, being in the field for 25, 26 years,
I realized that the basic science
is actually the easy part.
It's the implementation science
that's a lot more difficult.
Showing that these
treatments are effective,
determining who they're effective for,
and then getting it, even
once it crosses the goal line,
how do you actually get it to patients?
These are some real struggles.
- I think the other
thing I didn't mention,
I'll be mad at myself
if I don't bring up,.
I've talked about treatments
and access treatments,
better treatments, those things.
I think the other thing that I talk about
in my article, and I tried
to talk about all the time.
And if you sit down with me,
we're gonna have a long
conversation about it,
but it's about also the
importance of the relationship
between a doctor and the patient
and how in the system that we have built,
health constrained that becomes.
And really, I think the burden
that the healthcare system
places on doctors is
tremendous and on their time,
and they're reimbursed,
like all of these things.
And in turn, how that
impacts the relationship
with the patients and the communication.
And how, there are things
that I remember that Gerry said to me
while I was in the trial that I'm like,
I will forever hold that in my mind.
That I've had other
physicians who say things
they think really communicating,
being very clear to your patients.
Especially if they're not
responding to treatments
or you're in a position where it's like,
it's really hard to figure out.
You can be honest about that,
but to really communicate,
like, I am not giving up on
you and I'm in this with you.
And I have a team of psychiatrists.
And some of them, I get to hear them talk
because I'm at the university.
And so they're out
there talking, I get to.
And one of my physicians was
giving a lecture and someone,
there's a mixed audience
of like the public
and activist and neuroscientist.
All of a sudden someone spoke up of like,
what about someone who's
tried 20 medications?
What do you say to them?
And he said, no one has tried everything
and I will never give up on a patient.
And I mean, I believed him 100%.
Not only cause he's my doctor,
but that is for sure where he's at.
But how much longer that
can help someone hold on
and just give a little
more hope where it's like,
you're holding the hope for
the person who can't hold it.
That is very, very important.
And sometimes, there isn't anything to do.
Sometimes there's just in that moment,
nothing that can be done,
but I think acknowledging and
sitting down with the person
and their suffering
and really saying like,
I understand what it is
I'm asking you to do.
I understand by asking you to
stay around what that means.
'Cause I'm gonna, I'm listening to you.
I'm feeling it.
I'm believing you rather than just like,
this kind of, well, we'll
get around to it next time.
Or I don't know what to do and sorry,
but I think really being in it
with the person communicating
that is, that is medicine.
- Yeah, and it's hard in its
truest form and so powerful.
And the fact that those--
- Probably there's hope in medicine too.
- Yeah, yeah.
Very, very true.
I'm sure we knew we could,
if we had more time,
we can talk about the neuroscience of that
and what that's doing to our brains
and that the interaction there.
- I would love to sit
down another time, Nii
and go through that 'cause
that would be a great topic.
- Yeah.
Well, I'm grateful to both of you, I mean,
I feel like we talk through
a lot of important topics,
but then also just touch the
surface in some ways too.
There's so much there.
So definitely be happy to revisit
in some shape or form as well.
But to close, I did wanna
just ask both of you,
to share what gives you hope in this work.
And I know you both lose
that a little bit as well.
And then also, if there are any resources
that you want to share with listeners.
Ashley, we'll be sure to
actually put your piece
on the website too, so people
can access it pretty easily.
- Thank you.
- But Gerry, we'll start with you
and then have Ashley wrap up.
- So I do think for
depression that the advances
that have been made in the past 20 years
have been quite amazing.
The neurobiology, I think is decades ahead
of the clinical care.
In our understanding of some
of the basic neuro-biological
underpinnings of what we're talking about
when we talk about depression,
it's not homogeneous on this.
There's many different pathologies
or ways that you can get there.
And I think we're starting
to make real strides
in understanding that.
And if you think about the
availability of novel treatments,
I mean, really up until
the last few years,
almost every medication that
was available for depression
was based on the
mononeuropathy hypothesis.
This very hypothesis that was
developed in the early '60s
suggesting that
norepinephrine and serotonin,
to some extent, dopamine,
the basic model of
immunologic neurotransmitters
are the core of depression.
The neuroscience, for 40 years,
we've known that that could not account
for the basic pathology of depression,
the pathophysiology and the treatment.
What we've learned so much that now
in the past five to 10 years,
novel treatments have
been approved by the FDA
that do not target those
systems in any way,
such as S ketamine, version
of ketamine for depression
and another drug target
targeting the gabaergic system
for depression, for postpartum depression.
And many new drugs in the pipeline.
So we've sort of broken out of that box
that's constrained us for
nearly 50 years and opened up
a whole new vista of ways
of developing treatments.
But beyond that,
we've also developed novel
neuro stimulation treatments,
TMS treatments.
For years we've had ECT, but that was it.
Now we're really trying to find ways
to refine those treatments.
And we've also broken out
of the box of just accepting
the fact that it takes weeks to months
before somebody can benefit.
And Ashley can tell you one
day struggling with this
feels like an eternity.
I mean, when you tell somebody,
well, you'll feel better,
but you're gonna probably feel
worse before you feel better.
And it may take two months
before it's clinically noticeable.
We've broken out of that.
Now we know there are
treatments that can make people
feel better in a much
shorter period of time.
We still have a long way
to go to improve upon that.
But I think the advances
are quite real and tangible.
And I think the next few
decades will bring many more.
And I think the next few years
will actually help us
refine what we do have.
- Yeah, that's definitely encouraging.
Appreciate you putting that perspective
and giving that perspective
for our listeners as well.
Ashley, giving you the
floor for the closing,
the closing words.
- Oh gosh.
- No pressure.
- Yeah, no, I think
conversations like this
or your podcasts,
I've listened to almost
every episode at this point.
Those things give me hope I think.
We are having a more public
than ever about these things
and you are making some
significant strides
in our awareness, how
we think about things,
how we talk about things.
I think the pandemic is definitely pushing
our healthcare system
actually, as I think,
just push away past the brink.
And I think we're gonna be
forced to reconsider this system
that we've built.
And I'm hoping that,
I think we're gonna see a
large mental health fall out
from this if we're not already seeing it
and what we build and
imagine in the future,
we'll have to consider that.
Whether we choose to or not,
it's gonna be in our faces.
So in some ways, I feel
hopeful about that.
I also think, nationally
and internationally,
along with the pandemic,
there's I think more awareness
of racism and oppression.
And these kinds of things are
challenging us to figure out
how do we cause harm?
How do we help and how do we
show up for each other in a way
that I think is a really different,
at least for me personally,
has a very different quality
and a very different conversation.
And I think as we learned to
show up for each other better,
I think both we can reduce
depression from it happening
to begin with, but then also,
have have more resources and
supports to get people help.
So yeah, that's where I'm at.
- Really well said.
When you put that, put
that in great context too.
Again, we touched the tip of the iceberg,
but we also covered a lot.
And I think, I mean,
just a level of honesty
and sincerely that you both share too,
I think that's gonna be really
important for a lot of folks.
And also be curious about
questions people have
on this episode too.
So, I mean, at some point
we'll have to have round two
and continue the conversation.
But definitely appreciate
both of you being here.
Hope you both have a good holiday.
I know that can be challenging as well,
but some time to relax
and just grateful again
for where you all went
and just the investment
that you're both making
in so many different ways.
So thanks so much for joining
The Addy Hour podcast.
Appreciate both of you.
- Yeah, thanks so much for having me.
I would love to come
back if you'll have us.
- Okay, excellent.
- It was really my pleasure, Nii
and great seeing you again, Ashley.
- Great seeing you.
- Bye bye.
- Great to see both of you.
(upbeat music)